coup dur pour les restaurateurs qui
était déjà en difficulté
il sera interdit de circuler après 21h
dans les yvelines à partir de samedi au
lendemain des annonces de nombreuses
interrogations occupe les esprits
ça va être compliqué voit ça on verra on
verra pas qu'à partir de de la semaine
prochaine comment sans mal géré et
comment seront les gens si s'ils seront
toujours présents déjà d'une part et et
comment on les répartit à une fermeture
à 21h qui aura des conséquences sur la
gestion du personnel
puisqu'on va perdre quatre heures le
soir donc évidemment il y aura des gens
au chômage partiel à juziers dans ce
restaurant les clients viennent
d'habitude vers 20h30
cette fois pas le choix il faudra
adapter le service du soir on va
commencer à partir de 18 heures alors
est ce qu'il va voir du monde ou pas je
suis pas convaincu mais voilà de 18
heures jusqu'à 20 heures on va dire
jusqu'à 20h pouvoir prendre des tables
dernière table à 20 heures le temps que
les gens puissent puissent manger tout
et qu'en gros à 20h45
20h50 que le service soit terminée quoi
les propriétaires de l'atelier de gaëtan
ont perdu presque cent mille euros de
chiffre d'affaires cette année une perte
considérable pour une petite structure
comme celle ci qui correspond à nos
trois mois de fermeture plus une grosse
partie traiteur que nous avons aussi en
moins parce que sur l'événementiel en ce
moment nous n'avons quasiment plus rien
les restaurants qui comptent moins de 50
salariés pourront compter sur le fonds
de solidarité à partir de 50 % de perte
de chiffre d'affaires l'aide pourra
aller jusqu'à dix mille euros